gentlemen desperate times desperate  measures  the head of the Belgian government  selected you the mission subjected to  transporting a cargo of raw materials of  crucial importance at the end why are  you going to find it prove it's up to  this we selected a group of loyal well  trained  and welcome to Africa what's this a  German camp he's going to train this is  a highly complex machine you man had  better brace yourself you've got three  weeks to learn it we've got to pilot  this ourselves those of you who aren't  very good in geography we are right here  and our destination America  take us down  [Music]  god help us which was it  [Music]  are you sure it's an impossible job do I  do  let's cut this bleep out  you